question how do you feel about uh
the ufc like like like when these
celebrity fights happen
when a ufc fighter fights a youtube
fighter or did that ever happen
yeah yeah yeah well there's a kid right
now that that's fighting that kid uh
jake paul that he uh one one of our
fighters who's retired but he's boxing
and he's a wrestler
he's boxing he's wrestling he's boxing
against him and this kid's a wrestler
and the guy has to wrestle with boxers
right yeah he's with grubs well he
should box
a boxing then boxer boxer but [ __ ]
listen let's be honest jake paul isn't a
[ __ ] boxer this guy's a [ __ ]
two kids yeah he be working hard though
he's a great friend working hard i watch
him i watch them i see him
i see them putting together a jab no
[ __ ] i'm just saying
though you're hanging out with the kid
you know on me
you know you know whatever so you're
saying you're saying he could fight
yes all right
zach said that that is a that is a very
broad question who can he
fight right when you say fighting can he
fight
[ __ ] yeah can this [ __ ] guy fight
over here yeah
you know what i'm saying can this kid
fight now can you fight mike tyson this
is no
way mike tyson can fight listen i get it
you're in a bad position right now
because you hang out with the kid you
know him at the gym and [ __ ]
you don't want to [ __ ] all over the
place no no no no can this kid fight
one thing about me you know i should i
shoot straight [ __ ]
can he fight the boy let me tell you
about this kid so the kid that he's
going to fight is a wrestler
you know a real good wrestler decorated
wrestler
but he's he's actually fought real guys
he he he's been a world champion in
other organizations it'll be an
interesting test yeah but it's different
though dana when you're standing up
and you you know from wrestling and
standing up and let them hand fly
one thing i can't say about him he got
hands yeah he got hands
yeah yo you i i'm
i'm not joking he's got hands he's very
excited but i want to see him fight
again
fight again yeah
he talks a lot of [ __ ] oh man he does
that's why that's why he got like
75 million views that watches him
everything yeah
they he management they watch him and i
watch it for no reason we're gonna find
out
we're gonna find out here pretty soon
yeah yeah now
let me tell you what i hope you can bet
on this thing because i'll [ __ ]
i'll bet a million dollars oh here we go
he loses this [ __ ] fight
they know why
he loses this fight a million so i hope
we can bet on this
i love this guy paul this guy look he
got his millions
wow danny's not playing
[Music]
you